I also downtown Las Vegas continues to
really evolve now the addition of
another high-rise is coming into the mix
it will be located on Grand Central
Parkway and Symphony Park Avenue right
by the Smith Center and World Market 8
news now reporter Brian will tells us
about the newest changes coming to that
area
the addition of two new luxury apartment
complexes here near Symphony Park
continue to add to the ever-changing
landscape that is downtown Las Vegas
developments continue to roll through
downtown it has come a long way since
the start of revitalizing the area in
the 90s the population grew and suburbs
began to spring up downtown really
became crime infested and very
deteriorated because there were new
places to live the additions of the
Cleveland Clinic World Market Center
Circa an expansion of Fremont East is
What attracted this most recent
development to the area in a section
that used to be an empty Brown lot never
would I have ever thought that we would
have this amount of development and that
Symphony Park would be the premier
destination spot for development also
for residents after Cova delays and
rescheduling the project for a new
22-story high ride and a five-story
apartment complex will join an existing
luxury property the lack of residential
housing drove developer Tim Downey to
build here there's a lot of wonderful
housing in the suburbs but downtown
could use some really nice housing and
nice beautiful place this development is
funded through private investments from
Southern Land Company with the average
cost of rent at about 3 000 a month
we've got the plasma looking to do some
stuff Downtown Grand it's at a big
expansion you've got what's going on in
Symphony Park or parkhaven this project
happening with southern land it is just
great to see the amount of development
the more than 500 Apartments will be
complete in the next few years reporting
in downtown Las Vegas Brian will eight
news now